all right let's get into the mailbag
info davidpakman.com info
davidpakman.com
info
davidpakman.com keep them polite keep
them quick keep them substantive
and maybe it'll make the show
or some people try other approaches
let's start with our first email today
from
cune i think it's pronounced
trump your podcast
i wonder if you would be so kind as to
tell me who in the democratic party is
paying and how much
nobody from the democratic party is
paying me anything
george soros is not paying anything
the uh
klaus schwab is not paying any none of
them are paying anything
we exist
thanks to our audience our viewers
through a number of revenue sources
including uh membership
and youtube ads facebook ads you do
these types of things all right so
whoever you think is paying us
they are not unless you're talking about
our audience but thank you for asking
rebecca rhoden
rebecca says please take down your video
biden making fun of trump for
covid19's
experience
p.s
you can't trump fat
you are not fat and only fat people can
call other people fat
then it's okay skinny man please don't
show my email address thank you call me
mona well listen it's not about me
calling people fat
it's about
trump is obviously lying about his
height and weight
and when we think about your ability to
deal with something like covid
one's weight and condition
is a big factor in determining
you know
what is going to be a more or less
likely outcome
and um donald trump is obese i mean it's
not it's not a pejorative he's just
obese it's all it is all right rebecca
slash mona we are not taking the video
down the video is staying up thank you
very much we will manage the youtube
channel as we see fit
teresa from san francisco wrote in with
a question about anthony fauci teresa
says hi david you mentioned recently
that elements in the republican party
are gearing up to investigate dr fauci's
handling of the pandemic if they retake
the house and or senate in the midterms
if this happens do you think it would be
possible for president biden to pardon
dr fauci preemptively or otherwise
listen the answer is yes there's two
issues here that i think about when i
hear oh just pardon fouchy preemptively
to protect him okay number one
republicans will go
nuts absolutely nuts
they will treat it as if trump had
preemptively pardoned don jr even though
the circumstances would be completely
different don jr may genuinely have been
involved in crimes dr fauci is a public
health official who conspiracy theorists
and extremists have
created a vendetta against so one is
republicans would go so crazy who knows
what would happen and number two
it would be a really really sad
commentary on the state of the country
and we know the state of the country is
in the toilet but it would be a really
sad commentary on the state of the
country
for a president
to have to preemptively pardon
a career public health official who's
over 80 and is retiring because of
uh uh
the the rabid
attackers from the american right it
would just be such a sad situation but
yeah i mean biden could do it i hope it
really doesn't come to that
todd wrote in about trump rallies todd
asks
have you noticed it's the same black guy
in the background of all trump rallies i
only watch snip it's i like that that's
beautiful uh
snippets of his rallies when replayed on
shows like yours and i've seen the same
guy in the background at all his rallies
meaning that guy is traveling to all his
rallies being paid to attend so there's
two different things going on
i know the guy that todd is talking
about
i think that that guy is part of the
group blacks for trump
and um
it's everything about it is very unclear
we just we don't know about it we don't
want to offend anybody we don't want to
dismiss anyone's activism or anything
but there's something very odd about the
entire blacks for trump group they have
almost no presence online except for one
website which is just
very strange rants we don't really know
what to make of it it's all very very
weird
but
that's one thing separate from that is
the reality that like many republicans
republicans have very low support from
from black americans
republicans love
to put the black folks right on the
stage behind them to make the crowd
appear more diverse than it actually is
so it wouldn't be
shocking
if absent a natural black crowd
the trump campaign the trump people had
some
friends of the campaign of friends of
trump who they would fly around so they
would have black people on the stage
it's mere speculation i want to be clear
i'm not saying that's going on
i'm just saying it wouldn't
really surprise me
next email is from sean about republican
indoctrination
sean says sir if you want to see some
truly disturbing republican
indoctrination
look at prageru kids it pisses me off
that the american right claims that
schools are brainwashing our kids to be
communists when they talk about how they
want patriotic education
give me a break
sincerely
sean from minnesota 100
they say now um they are quote teaching
transgender to our kids to indoctrinate
them they are pushing puberty blockers
on kids much too young to even be near
puberty why would they do that doesn't
make sense
they are
pushing kids to be gay they are pushing
kids to be trans college is liberal
indoctrination they're making them
communists they're making them
socialists they're making all this
different stuff
we would never do that and then you look
at the
learning about trump for kids stuff that
mike huckabee promotes you look at
prageru kids
you look at all of the different ways
that they want churches indoctrinating
kids not just into a religious doctrine
most churches indoctrinate kids into
religious doctrine
but they want the church's
indoctrinating kids into a political
doctrine as well for which by the way
they should lose their nonprofit status
but they almost never do
100 correct sean that is exactly what
they are doing
dylan wrote in dylan says could the big
lie reduce voter turnout do you think
the big lie could reduce voter turnout
among those who believe it
trumpists who think the 2020 election
was stolen may not see any point in
voting and may not want to go out of
their way to vote interested to hear
your thoughts
100
in fact
last week marjorie taylor greene said
this marjorie taylor green last week
said she's worried
that the trump people
may not be that enthusiastic about
coming up to out to vote in november and
then she parroted the big lie
which is one of the reasons that
republicans sometimes don't come out to
vote the anecdote i mentioned last week
was the january five special election
senate elections in georgia remember
there were these two runoffs january 5
2021
and because trump and republicans spent
the two-month period between the
november election and the january
special elections basically just saying
it was all stolen
um
that
almost certainly reduced turnout in
january and arguably costs republicans
control of the senate that's what's
crazy they don't even seem to fully
understand
it's your narrative about the big lie
that is causing these problems for you
to begin with i hope they keep doing it
i mean it just hurts them
natalie wrote in about ar-15s david did
you see where they now have a new gun
the junior 15 the jr15 marketed the kids
we are in serious trouble but you knew
this love the show i did see the junior
15.
um it is
insane it is it's quite literally a
rifle marketed to children
it is uh the graphics on the i mean
everything about it is uh indicative of
an extraordinarily sick country
i i really don't know what else to say
about it it's
we just have special rifles marketed to
children here
it i i'm without any further words to
say
dominic from the uk wrote in and says hi
david whilst you and i understand trump
couldn't get reelected without the
backing of the republican party do you
think his low intellect coupled with his
high ego could convince him to run as an
independent if he fails to get the
republican nomination thus ensuring a
democrat victory in 2024 i think this is
a beautiful strategy the ideal scenario
for the left would be trump runs for the
nomination of the republican party but
loses someone else wins you know right
now desantis is the lead guy someone
else wins
trump
furious
decides to run
as an independent
he
siphons off
20 of the republican vote
and ensures that the democratic
candidate
cruises to victory i think it would be
absolutely fantastic he should be
encouraged to do so i do think speaking
realistically
that if trump lost the republican
nomination in 2024 his kids would be
able to talk him out of running as an
independent i think they'd say dad don't
do this to yourself
you had a good run you're almost 80.
screw him let's go and do something else
i do think his kids would be able to
talk him out of it
bobby wrote in
with an answer to what is a woman
that he says would shut down
conservatives
bobby writes david i keep hearing this
question and my mind is boggled that
neither you katanji brown jackson nor
any single sitting democrat or spokesman
for the lgbtq community has given this
simple response i majored in poli sci
and i'm a freelance writer next time
you're asked or please tell your
audience here is your response
all words have multiple definitions and
to quote the oxford dictionary
traditionally the preeminent dictionary
on the planet
the definition of a woman
is a person with the qualities
traditionally associated with females
this definition 100 describes
transgender women and i've never heard a
single democrat use it this would shut
up anyone that asks
uh sorry robert it's almost
quaint that you think that would be like
a whoa mic drop moment if you say to
them a person with the qualities
traditionally associated with females
they would go
like a vagina
and you just are opening up a whole new
can of worms and a whole discussion
i used to have these ideas like robert
where i would go
this is so dumb
here's the incontrovertible
mic drop hammer of an answer that'll
have them on their knees quivering
unable to respond
and then i'd realize wait a second they
always have a response that's not how
politics works if you if you use this
definition a woman is a person with the
qualities traditionally associated with
females they would go females have
particular genitalia
boom it's over
i'm not telling you
that their question what is a woman is
isn't bad faith i'm not saying any of
that
i'm just saying
trust me
that is not going to have the
powerful impact
that you think it will info
davidpakman.com get your thoughts in
questions comments ideas suggestions
and we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad such a good bonus show
that i won't even tell you what's on it
sign up at joinpakman.com